‏are
صلى الله عليه وسلم
عثمان طلحه
father
grandfather to father to
and the صلى الله عليه وسلم
notever the keys. Give him those and
give me these. Thank you, sir. He's
going to drive off my car.
‏prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
لا اله الا الله
عثمان طلحه
people
at that time
‏And the walls were more or less covered
with treaties,
agreements,
poetry,
portraits, whatever else that they deem
to be kind of a capsule for the
peak of their pride and society at
that time. Imagine it being the
Smithsonian mum. ‏it being
the pinnacle of their language of their
culture was inside the
and so they would the and people would
come inside and the propet
got inse to go inside the and people
would go and
stand
and as
‏and not you
come here out the
and the prop
and
someate
him
عن هسان
يا عثمان
لعلك سترى هذا المفتاح في يدي يوما
اضعه حيث شئت
عثمان
صلى الله عليه وسلم
رمضان
اقبل في كتيبه الحديد ومعه المهاجرون
والانصار
‏was
and was
so
and was around and around 360
id
kind of what you what day of the year it
was whatever you we got something
‏And so would each of these id as
wouldou
each
and جاء
طلحه
عثمان بن طلحه
اسامه ابن زيد عن بلال بنح
رضي الله عنهما
كعبه
‏enter
now
bir littleve
a p made out of sticks
that was in think what is that about
this go back to the culture of
time propy
‏sitting they would stone it and make it
run and it would they would if it fed
right I'm going to have a good day I
should continue with whatever it is I'm
doing it flies left better go home and
try again tomorrow right and ‏So they sy
with this birang
in the in house of
so the prop
and
on the wall the walls
and one of the
was that dep
and
عليه
ابراهيم
الازلام
الازلام صلاه العشاء
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الازلام
رجس من عمل الشيطان فاجتنبوه لعلكم تفلحون
اللهم
[Silence]
الازلام الازلام
الزلم الزلم
‏And basically what it is is it would
little rocks little pieces of wood or
most usually ars without without a
tip and with the with the
with the fins cut off right and they
would have inscribed on these three
arrows. Sometimes it was arrows the ones
at the seven arrows. ‏The ones at
were seven arrows and these arrows would
have things written on them do it
and don't do it and
try again or nothing right or what have
you. ‏a magic b
and so if a person was going to marry
someone or if a person was going to go
on a trip or even if a child was born
and they didn't know who the father was
they would draw straws
you know could be anyone so let's just
go to and have the come out and we will
draw and whoever's name comes up he's
the father because the universe tells
صلى الله عليه وسلم
كذبوا
ما
عمل ابراهيم واسماعيل بالازلام قطرايم
صلى الله عليه وسلم علين
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم اليوم
يوم بر ووفاء او اليوم يوم بر ووفاء
عثمان
طلحه
مفتاحك
خالده تالده
لا ينزعه منكم الا ظالم
عثمان طلحه
كعبه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
over time
because
this
‏take
and you a inart
if the com side
about you
side me nobody about you
how about youday you will someone
life
‏D could anybody they all my life right
you know 18 and 34 evening
things
will make a person
unaccept for 40 days
you don't believe it justing it for fun
just fun you know have a little with a
little what you know a
الله سبحانه وتالى
صلاه الاستخاره رب العالمين سبحانه وتعالى
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا
نساله تعالى ان يعيذنا من ان نشرك به شيء
ونحن نعلم ونستغفره مما لا نعلم والله
اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
[Silence]
الله
السلام
[Silence]
استووا واعتدلوا
الله
اكبر سبحانكمدك
وتنمك وت
خير من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
احل لكم صيد البحر وطعامه متاعا لكم
وللسياره
وحرم عليكم صيد البر ما دمتم حرما
واتقوا الله الذي اليه تحشرون
جعل الله الكعبه البيت الحرام قياما للناس
والشهر الحرام
والشهر الحرام الهدي والقلائد
ذلك لتعلموا ان الله يعلم ما في السماوات
وما في الارض وان الله بكل شيء عليم
اعلموا ان الله شديد العقاب وان الله غفور
رحيم
ما على الرسول
الا البلاغ
والله يعلم ما تبدون وما تكتمون
قل لا يستوي الخبيث والطيب ولو اعجبك كثره
الخبيث
فاتقوا الله يا اولي الالباب لعلكم
تفلحون
الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تسالوا عن اشياء
ان تبد لكم تسؤكم
وان تسالوا عنها حين ينزل القران تبد لكم
عفى الله عنها
والله غفر غفور حليم
قد سالها قوم من قبلكم ثم اصبحوا بها
كافرين
ما جعل الله من بحيره ولا سائبه
ولا وصيله ولا حام
ولكن الذين كفروا يفترون على الله الكذب
واكثر اثروهم لا يعقلون
واذا قيل لهم تعالوا الى ما انزل الله
والى الرسول قالوا حسبنا ما وجدنا عليه
اباءنا
اولو كان اباؤهم
لا يعلمون شيئا ولا يهتدون
يا ايها الذين امنوا
عليكم انفسكم
لا يضركم
من ضل اذا اهتديتم
الى الله مرجعكم جميعا فينبئكم
بما كنتم تعملون
يا ايها الذين امنوا شهاده بينكم اذا حضر
احدكم الموت حين
الوصيه اثنان ذوى عدل منكم
اثنان ذوى عدل منكم او اخران من غيركم ان
انتم ضربتم في الارض فاصابتكم
مصيبه الموت
تحبسونهما
من بعد الصلاه فيقسمان بالله ان ارتبتم لا
نشتري به ثمنا ولو كان ذا قربى
ولو كان ذا قربى ولا نكتم
لا نشتري به ثمنا ولو كان ذا قربى ولا
نكتم شهاده الله انا اذا لمن الاثمين
فان عثر على انهما استحقا اثم من فاخران
يقومان مقامهما من الذين استحق عليهم
الاوليان
فيقسمان بالله لشهادتنا
احق شهادتهما
وما اعتدينا
انا اذا لمن الظالمين
ذلك ادنى ان ياتوا بالشهاده على وجههم
او يخافوا ان ترد ايمان بعد ايمانهم
واتقوا الله واسمعوه
والله لا يهدي القوم الفاسقين
الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر سبحان ربي سبحان
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
صل
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط راط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
يوم يجمع الله الرسل فيقول ماذا اجبتم
قالوا لا علم لنا انك انت علام الغيوب
اذ قال الله يا عيسى ابن مريم اذكر نعمتي
عليك وعلى والدتك
اذ ايدتك بروح القدس تكلم الناس في المهد
وكهلا
واذ علمتك الكتاب والحكمه والتوراه
والانجيل
واذ تخلق من الطين كهيئه الطير باذن اذني
فتنفخ فيها فتكون طيرا باذني
وتبرئ الاكمه والابرص باذني واذ تخرج
الموتى باذني
واذ كففت بني اسرائيل
عنك اذ جئتهم بالبينات
فقال الذين كفروا منهم ان هذا الا سحر
مبين
واذ اوحيت الى الحواريين ان امنوا بي
وبرسولي
قالوا امنا
بالله واشهد باننا مسلمون
قالوا امنا واشهد باننا مسلمون
اذ قال الحواريون يا عيسى ابن مريم هل
يستطيع ربك
هل يستطيع ربك ان ينزل علينا مائده
من السماء؟
قال اتقوا الله ان كنتم مؤمنين
قالوا نريد ان ناكل منها وتطمئن
قلوبنا
ونعلم ان قد صدقتنا ونكون كون عليها من
الشاهدين
قال عيسى ابن مريم اللهم ربنا انزل علينا
انزل علينا مائده
من السماء
تكون لنا عيدا
تكون لنا عيدا لاولنا واخرنا وايه منك
وارزقنا
وارزقنا وانت خير الرازقين.
قال الله اني منزلها عليكم فمن يكفر بعد
منكم فاني اعذبه عذابا لا اعذبه احدا من
العالمين.
واذ قال الله يا عيسى ابن مريم اانت قلت
للناس اتخذوني وامي الهين
اانت قلت للناس اتخذوني وامي الهين من دون
الله
قال سبحانك ما يكون لي ان اقول ما ليس لي
بحق
ان كنتم قلته فقد علمته
تعلم ما في نفسي ولا اعلم ما في نفسك وانت
انك انت علام الغيوب
ما قلت لهم الا ما امرتني به ان اعبدوا
الله ربي وربكم
وكنت
عليهم شهيدا
ما دمت فيهم
فلما توفيتني كنت انت الرقيب عليهم
وانت على كل شيء شهيد
ان تعذبهم فانهم عبادك
وان تغفر لهم فانك انت العزيز الحكيم
قال الله هذا يوم ينف ع الصادقين صدقهم
لهم جنات
تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها
خالدين فيها ابدا رضي الله عنهم ورضوا عنه
ذلك الفوز العظيم
لله ملك السماوات والارض وما فيهن
وهو على كل شيء
قدير
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله الذي جعل الحمد لله الذي خلق
السماوات والارض
وجعل الظلمات والنور
ثم الذين كفروا بربهم
يعدلون
هو الذي خلقكم من طين ثم قضى اجلا
واجل مسمترون
وهو الله في السماوات وفي الارض يعلم سركم
وجهركم ويعلم ما تكسبون
وما تاتيهم من ايه من ايات ربهم الا كانوا
عنها معرضين
فقد كذبوا بالحق لما جاءهم
فسوف ياتيهم انباء
ما كانوا به يستهزئون
الم يروا كم اهلكنا من قبلهم من قرن
مكناهم
في الارض مك كناهم في الارض ما لم نمكن
لكم وارسلنا السماء عليهم مدرارا
وجعلنا الانهار تجري من تحتهم فاهلكناهم
بذنوبهم وجعلنا من بعدهم قرنا اخرين
وانشانا من بعدهم قرنا اخرين
ولو نزلنا عليك كتابا في قرطاس فلمسوه
بايديهم
لقال الذين كفروا ان هذا الا سحر مبين
وقالوا لولا انزل عليه ملك ولو انزلنا
ملكا لقضي الامر ثم لا ينظرون
ولو جعلناه ملكا لجعلناه رجلا وللبسنا
عليهم ما يلبسون
ولقد استهزئ برسل من قبلك فحاق بالذين
سخروا منهم
فحاق بالذين سخروا منهم ما كانوا به
يستهزئون
قل سيروا في الارض ثم انظروا كيف كان
عاقبه المكذبين
قل لمن ما في السماوات والارض قل لله
كتب على نفسه الرحمه ليجمعنكم
الى يوم القيامه
ليجمعنكم
الى يوم القيامه لا ريب فيه
الذين خسروا انفسهم
فهم لا يؤمنون
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال الضالين
امين
وله ما سكن في الليل والنهار وهو السميع
العليم قل اغير الله اتخذ وليا
فاطر السماوات والارض وهو يطعم ولا يطعم
قل اني امرت ان اكون اول من اسلم ولا
تكونن من المشركين
قل اني اخاف ان عصيت ربي عذاب
يوم عظيم
من يصرف عنه يومئذ فقد رحمه وذلك هو الفوز
المبين وان ينسسك الله بضر ر فلا كاشف له
الا هو
وان يمسسك بخير فهو على كل شيء قدير
وهو القاهر فوق عباده وهو الحكيم الخبير
قل اي شيء اكبر شهاده
قل الله شهيد بيني وبينكم
واوحي الي هذا القران لانذركم
به ومن بلغ اانكم لتشهدون ان مع الله الهه
اخرى قل لا اشهد
قل انما هو اله واحد وانني بريء
مما تشركون
الذين اتيناهم
الكتاب يعرفونه كما يعرفون ابناءهم
الذين خسروا انفسهم فهم لا يؤمنون
ومن اظلم ممن افترى على الله كذبا او كذب
باياته
انه لا يفلح الظالمون
ويوم نحشرهم جميعا ثم نقول للذي الذين
اشركوه
ثم نقول للذين اشركوا اين شركاؤكم
الذين كنتم تزعمون
ثم لم تكن فتنتهم الا ان قالوا والله ربنا
ما كنا مشركين
انظر كيف كذبوا على انفسهم
وضل
عنهم ما كانوا يفترون
ومنهم من يستمع اليكي
وجعلنا على قلوبهم اكنه ان يفقهوه وفي
اذانهم وقرا وان يروا كل ايه لا يؤمنوا
بها حتى اذا جاؤوك
يجادلونك
يقول الذين كفروا
يقول الذين كفروا ان هذا الا اساطير
الاولين
وهم ينهون عنه ويون عنه وان يهلكون الا
انفسهم وما يشعرون
ولو ترى اذ وقفوا على النار فقالوا يا
ليتنا
فقالوا يا ليتنا نرد ولا نكذب بايات ربنا
ونكون من المؤمنين
بل بدى لهم ما كانوا يخفون من قبل
ولو ردوا لعادوا لما نهوا عنه وانهم
لكاذبون
وقالوا ان هي الا حياتنا الدنيا وما نحن
بمبعوثين
ولو ترى اذ وقفوا على ربهم قال اليس هذا
بالحق
قالوا بلى وربنا
قال فذوقوا العذاب بما كنتم تكفرون
قد خسر الذين كذبوا بلقاء
الله حتى اذا جاءتهم
ساعه حتى اذا جاءتهم
الساعه بغته قالوا يا حسرتنا على ما فرطنا
فيها
وهم يحملون اوزارهم على ظهورهم الا ساء
ما يزرون
وما الحياه الدنيا الا لعب ولهو
ولا الدار الاخره
خير للذين يتقون افلا تعقلون
قد نعلم انه ليحزنك الذي يقولون
فانهم لا يكذبونك
ولكن الظالمين بايات الله يجحدون
ولقد كذبت رسل من قبلك فصبروا على ما
كذبوا واوذوا
فصبروا على ما كذبوا واوذوا حتى اتاهم
نصرنا
ولا مبدل لكلمات الله ولقد جاءك من نبا
المرسلين
وان كان كبر عليك اعراضهم
فان استطعت ان تبتغي نفقا
في الارض او سلما
او سلما
في السماء
فتاتيهم
بايه
ولو شاء الله لجمعهم على الهدى
فلا تكونن
من الجاهلين
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Arabic recitation]
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
انما يستجيب الذين يسمعون
والموتى يبعثهم الله ثم اليه يرجعون
وقوا
لولا نزل عليه ايه من ربه قل ان الله قادر
على ان ينزل ايه ولكن اكثرهم لا يعلمون
وما من دابه
في الارض ولا طائر
يطير بجناحيه الا امم امثالكم
ما فرطنا في الكتاب من شيء ثم الى ربهم
يحشرون
والذين كذبوا باياتنا صم وبكم في الظلمات
من يشا يضلله ومن يشاء يجعله على صراط
مستقيم
قل ارايتكم ان اتاكم عذاب الله او اتتكم
الساعه
الله تدعون
اغير الله تدعون ان كنتم صادقين
بل اياه تدعون فيكشف ما تدعون اليه
بل اياه تدعون فيكشف ما تدعون اليه ان شاء
وتنسون
ما تشركون
ولقد ارسلنا الى امم من قبلك فاخذناهم
الباساء
والضراء
لعلهم يتضرعون
فلولا اذ جاءهم باسنا تضرعوه
ولكن قست قلوبهم وزين لهم الشيطان ما
كانوا يعملون
فلما نسوا ما ذكروا به فتحنا عليهم ابواب
كل شيء
حتى اذا فرحوا بما اوتوا اخذناهم بغته
فاذا هم مبلسون
فقطع دابر القوم الذين ظلموا والحمد لله
رب العالمين
قل ارايتم ان اخذ الله سمعكم وابصاركم
وختم على قلوبكم
من اله غير الله ياتيكم به انظر كيف نصرف
الايات ثم
هم يصدفون
قل ارايتكم ان اتاكم عذاب الله بغته او
جهره هل يهلك الا القوم هل يهلك الا القوم
الظالمون
وما نرسل المرسلين الا مبشرين ومنذرين
فمن امن واصلح فلا خوف عليهم ولا هم
يحزنون
والذين كذبوا
باياتنا يمسهم العذاب بما كانوا يفسقون
قل لا اقول لكم عندي خزائن
الله ولا اعلم الغيب
ولا اعلم الغيب ولا اقول لكم اني ملك ان
اتبع الا ما يوحى الي قل هل يستوي الاعمى
والبصير
قل هل يستوي الاعمى والبصير قل هل يستوي
الاعمى والبصير
افلا تتفكرون
وانذر به الذين يخافون ان يحشروا الى ربهم
ليس لهم
ليس لهم من دونه ولي
ولا شفيع لعلهم يتقون
ولا تطرد الذين يدعون ربهم بالغداه والعشي
يريدون وجهه
ما عليك من حسابهم من شيء وما من حسابك
عليهم من شيء
فتطردهم فتكون من الظالمين
وكذلك فتنا بعضهم ببعض ليقولوه
ليقولوا اهؤلاء
من الله عليهم من بيننا
اليس الله باعلم بالشاكرين
واذا جاءك الذين يؤمنون باياتنا فقل سلام
فقل سلام عليكم كتب ربكم على نفسه الرحمه
انه من عمل منكم سوءا بجهاله
ثم
تاب من بعده واصلح فانه غفور رحيم وكذلك
نفصل الايات ولتستبين سبيل المجرمين
قل اني نهيت ان اعبد الذين تدعون من دون
الله
قل لا اتبع اهواءكم
قد ضللت اذا وما انا من المهتدين
قل اني على بينه من ربي وكذبتم به ما عندي
ما تستعجلون به ان الحكم الا لله
يقص الحق وهو خير الفاصلين
قل لو ان عندي ما تستعجل
به لقضي الامر بيني وبينكم
والله اعلم بالظالمين
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
وعنده
مفاتح الغيب لا يعلمها الا هو ويعلم ما في
البر والبحر وما تسقط من ورقه الا يعلمها
ولا حبه في ظلمات الارض ولا رطب ولا يابس
الا في كتاب مبين
وهو الذي يتوفاكم
بالليل ويعلم ما جرحتم بالنهار
ثم يبعثكم فيه ليقضى اجل مسمى
ثم اليه مرجع يرجعكم ثم
ينبئكم
بما كنتم تعملون
وهو القاهر فوق عباده ويرسل عليهم حفظه
حتى اذا جاء احدكم الموت توثه رسلنا
توثته رسلنا وهم لا يفرطون
وهو القاهر فوق عباده ويرسل عليكم حفظه
حتى اذا جاء احدكم الموت توفته رسلنا وهم
لا يفرطون
ثم ردوا الى الله مولاهم الحق الا له
الحكم وهو اسرع الحاسبين
قل من ينجيكم
من ظلمات البر والبحر تدعونه
تدعونه تضرعا وخفيه
تدعونه تضرعا وخفيه لئن انجانا من هذه
لنكونن
من الشاكرين
قل الله ينجيكم
منها ومن كل كرب ثم انتم تشركون
وهو القادر على ان يبعث عليكم عذابا من
فوقكم او من تحت ارجلكم
او يلبسكم شيعا ويذيق بعضكم باس بعض
انظر كيف نصرف الايات لعلهم يفقهون
وكذب به قومك وهو الحق
قل لست عليكم بوكي
لكل نبا مستقر
وسوف تعلمون
واذا رايت الذين يخوضون في اياتنا فاعرض
عنهم
فاعرض عنهم حتى يخوضوا في حديث غيره واما
ينسينك
الشيطان
فلا تقعد بعد الذكرى مع القوم الظالمين
وما على الذين يتقون من حسابهم من شيء
ولكن
ذكرى لعلهم يتقون
وذر الذين اتخذوا دينهم لعبا ولهوا وغرتهم
وغرتهم الحياه الدنيا
وذكر به ان تبسل نفس بما كسبت ليس لها من
دون الله ليس لها من دون الله ولي ولا
شفيع
وان تعدل كل عدل لا يؤخذ منها
اولئك الذين ابسلوا بما كسبوا لهم شراب
من حميم
وعذاب اليم بما كانوا يكفرون
قل اندع من دون الله ما لا ينفعنا ولا
يضرنا
ونرد على اعقابنا بعد اذ هدانا الله
ونرد على اعقابنا بعد اذ هدانا الله كالذي
استهوته الشياطين قيل في الارض حيران
حيران له اصحاب يدعونه الى الهدناه
قل ان
ان
هدى الله هو الهدى وامرنا لنسلم لرب
العالمين
وان اقيموا الصلاه واتقوه وهو الذي اليه
تحشرون
وهو الذي خلق السماوات والارض بالحق ويوم
يقول كن فيكون
قوله الحق وله الملك يوم يوم ينفخ في
الصور
عالم الغيب والشهاده
وهو الحكيم الخبير
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضال الضالين
امين
واذ قال ابراهيم لابيه ازر اتتخذ اصناما
الهه اني اراك وقومك في ضلال مبين
وكذلك نري ابراهيم ملك ملكوت السماوات
والارض وليكون من الموقنين
فلما جن عليه الليل راى كوكبا قال هذا ربي
فلما افل قال لا احب الافلين
فلما راى القمر بازغا قال هذا ربي فلما
افل قال لئن لم يهدني ربي لاكونن
من القوم الضال ضالين
فلما راى الشمس بازغه قال هذا ربي هذا
اكبر فلما افلت قال يا قوم اني
بريء
مما تشركون
اني وجهت وجهي للذي فطر السماوات
والارض حنيفا وما انا من المشركين
وحاجه
قومه قال اتحاجوني
في الله وقد هدان
ولا اخاف ما تشركون به الا ان يشاء ربي
شيئا وسع ربي كل شيء علما افلا تتذكرون
وكيف اخاف ما اشركتم ولا تخافوا
انكم اشركتم بالله ما لم ينزل به عليكم
سلطانا
فاي الفريقين احق بالامن ان كنتم تعلمون
الذين امنوا ولم يلبسوا ايمانهم بظلم
اولئك لهم الامن وهم مهتدون
وتلك حجتنا
اتيناها ابراهيم
على قومه نرفع درجات من نشاء
ان ربك حكيم عليم
ووهبنا له اسحاق ويعقوب كلا هدينا ونوحا
هدينا من قبل ومن ذريته داوود
وسليمان وايوب ويوسف وموسى وهارون
وكذلك نجزي المحسنين
وزكريا ويحيى وعيسى والياس كل من الصالحين
واسماعيل واليسع ويونس ولوطا وكلا فضلنا
على العالمين
ومن ابائهم وذرياتهم واخوانهم
واجتبيناهم وهديناهم الى صراط مستقيم
ذلك هدى الله يهدي به من يشاء من عباده
ولو اشركوا لحبط عنهم ما كانوا يعملون
اولئك الذين اتيناهم الكتاب والحكم
والنبوه
فان يكفر بها هؤلاء فقد وكلنا بها قوما
ليسوا بها بكافرين
اولئك
الذين هدى الله فبهداه مقتده قل لا اسالكم
عليه اجرا ان هو الا ذكرى للعالمين
وما قدروا الله حق قدره اذ قالوا ما انزل
الله على بشر من شيء
قل من انزل الكتاب الذي جاء به موسى نورا
وهدى للناس تجعلونه قراطيس تبدونها وتخفون
كثيرا
وعلمتم ما لم تعلموا انتم ولا اباؤكم
قل الله ثم ذرهم في خوضهم يلعبون
وهذا كتاب انزلناه مبارك مصدق الذي بين
يديه لتنذر ام القرى ومن حولها
والذين يؤمنون بالاخره يؤمنون به وهم على
صلاتهم يحافظون
ومن اظلم ممن افترى على الله كذبا او قال
اوحي الي ولم يوحى اليه شيء ومن قال سانزل
مثل ما انزل الله
ولو ترى اذ الظالمون في غمرات الموت
والملائكه
باسطوا ايديهم اخرجوا انفسكم
اخرجوا انفسكم اليوم تجزون عذاب الهون بما
كنتم تقولون على الله غير الحق وكنتم عن
اياته تستكبرون
ولقد جئتمونا فرادا كما خلقناكم اول مره
وتركتم ما خولناكم وراء ظهوركم
وما نرى معكم شفعاءكم
الذين زعمتم انهم فيكم شركاء
لقد تقطع بينكم وضل عنكم ما كنتم تزعمون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ان الله فالق الحب والنوى
يخرج الحي من الميت ومخرج الميت من الحي
ذلكم الله فانا تؤفكون
فالق الاصباح وجعل الليل سكنا والشمس
والقمر حسبانا ذلك تقدير العزيز العليم
وهو الذي جعل لكم النجوم لتهتدوا بها في
ظلمات البر والبحر قد فصلنا الايات لقوم
يعلمون
وهو الذي انشاكم
من نفس واحده فمستقر
ومستودع قد فصلنا الايات لقوم يفقهون
وهو الذي انزل من السماء
ماء فاخرجنا به نبات كل شيء فاخرجنا منه
خضرا
نخرج منه حبا متراكبا ومن النخل من طلعها
قنوان ذانيه وجنات من اعناب
وجنات من اعناب والزيتون والرمان مشتبها
وغير متشابه به انظروا الى ثمره اذا اثمر
وينعه
ان في ذلكم لايات لقوم يؤمنون
وجعلوا لله شركاء
الجن وخلقهم وخرقوا له بنين وبنات بغير
علم سبحانه وتعالى عما يصفون
بديع السماوات والارض اما يكون له ولد ولم
تكن له صاحبه وخلق كل شيء وهو بكل شيء
عليم
ذلكم الله ربكم لا اله الا هو خالق كل شيء
وهو على كل شيء وكيل
فاعبدوه
لا تدركه الابصار وهو يدرك الابصار وهو
اللطيف الخبير
قد جاءكم
بصائر من ربكم فمن ابصر فلنفسه ومن عمي
فعليها وما انا عليكم بحفيظ
وكذلك نصرف الايات وليقولوا درست ولنبينه
لقوم يعلمون
اتبع ما اوحي اليك من ربك لا اله الا هو
واعرض عن المشركين
ولو شاء الله ما اشركوا
ولو شاء الله ما اشركوا وما جعلناك عليهم
حفيظا وما انت عليهم بوكيل
ولا تسب الذين يدعون من دون الله فيسب
الله عدوا بغير علم كذلك زيننا لكل امه
عملهم ثم الى ربهم مرجعهم فينبئهم بما
كانوا يعملون
واقسموا بالله جهد ايمانهم لئن جاءتهم
ايه ليؤمنن بها قل انما الايات عند الله
وما يشعركم انها اذا جاءت لا يؤمنون
ونقلب افئدتهم وابصارهم كما لم يؤمنوا به
اول مره ونذر هم في طغيانهم يعمهون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله.
الشفع والوتر ان شاء الله صلاه الشفع
والوتركهدشهد
ركعه
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه فصلى بل
تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا والاخره خير وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف الاولى صحف ابراهيم
وموسى
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغ المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
اذا جاء نصر الله والفتح ورايت الناس
يدخلون في دين الله افواجا
فسبح بحمد ربك واستغفره انه كان توابا
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط راط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
اللهم لك الحمد انت نور السماوات والارض
ومن فيهن ولك الحمد انت قيوم السماوات
والارض ومن فيهن ولك الحمد انت ملك
السماوات والارض ومن فيهن
اللهم لك الحمد فانت الحق وقولك حق ووعدك
حق ولقاؤك حق والساعه حق والجنه حق والنار
حق والنبيون حق ومحمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
حق اللهم لك اسلمنا وعليك توكلنا وبك امنا
واليك انبنا
وبك خاصنا
واليك حاكمنا
فاغفر اللهم لنا ما قدمنا وما اخرناه
وما اسررنا وما اعلناه وما انت اعلم به
منا انت المقدم وانت المؤخر ولا اله الا
انت
اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن توليت
وبارك اللهم لنا فيما اعطيت وقنا واصرف
عنا برحمتك شر ما قضيت انك تقضي بالحق ولا
يقضى عليك انه لا يذل من واليت ولا يعز من
عاديت تباركت ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك نستغفرك
اللهم من كل ذنب وخطيئه ونتوب اليك
ونؤمن بك ونتوكل عليك ونكل اليك الامر كله
اللهم احينا ما دامت الحياه خيرا لنا
وتوفنا ما دامت الوفاه خيرا لنا واجعل
اللهم الحياه زياده لنا من كل خير واجعل
الموت راحه لنا من كل شر اللهم انا نسالك
عيشه هنيه وميته سويه ومرب ردا غير مخز
ولا فاضح
اللهم تقبل منا الصيام والقيام اللهم تقبل
منا الصيام والقيام اللهم تقبل منا الصيام
والقيام
اللهم لك قلنا اللهم بين يديك قمنا ولك
ركعنا ولك سجدنا ولك اسلمنا وبك امنا
خشعت لنا خش شعت لك اسماعنا وابصارنا
وامخاخنا واعصابنا
وقلوبنا وعظامنا
وما استقلت به اقدامنا
لا اله الا انت اللهم انا نعوذ برضاك من
سخطك وبمعافاتك من عقوبتك ونعوذ بك منك لا
نحصي ثناء عليك انت كما اثنيت على نفسك
اللهم اغفر لنا الذنوب واستر منا العيوب
وتب علينا يا مولانا كي نتوب
اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا كلها دقها وجلها
اولها واخرها ما علمنا منها وما لم نعلم
برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين رب اغفر وارحم
واعف وتكرم وتجاوز عما تعلم
انك تعلم ما لا نعلم انك انت الله الاعز
الاكرم
واخر دعوانا ان الحمد لله رب العالمين وصل
اللهم وسلم وزد وبارك على سيدنا محمد وعلى
اله وصحبه اجمعين
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
سبحانك
سبحان الملك القدوس سبحان
الملك القدوس
[Silence]
كيف حالك
السلام
[Silence]
الاول
السلام عليكم
[Silence]
الشيخ ابو غازي
اكثر واحد عاص
مره اجيب
متابع معان
[Arabic recitation]